hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
this is Taylor Robinson from the channel
finally Taylor where you can catch a lot
of awesome reactions on there I
subscribe to her channel she has yet to
subscribe to the real rejects gotta work
a little harder I I respect that check
out a video from one of my favorite
YouTube channels what culture 8
legendary duo's who hated each other's
guts I have a feeling Mulder and Scully
are gonna be on here probably because I
saw the thumbnail I like Ryan Gosling
and Rachel McAdams for when they worked
on the notebook but they did but they
they're known to hate each other
Patrick Swayze and the chick from
Dancing good things look on screen stand
away from the cameras on
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
here in their normal people remember
that they actually spent a full decade
as a comedy duo in fifties well this
show is a great platform to waste the
singing talents in all these handsome
isn't Martin who slowly began to take a
back seat to their acting who's even
left out of magazine covers I feel you
bro naturally it's put a strain on their
workers Lewis interpreted Martin's
dissatisfactory as a lack of effort into
unable to break this cycle it all ended
in an acrimonious split Dean turning to
his former friend and telling him you're
nothing to me but to beyond simply me
and Cleary there is more to the Rolling
Stones than just Jagger and Richards the
two are responsible for 99% of the
creative genius behind the group and
over the years have become like brothers
to each other albeit brothers who have
had a tendency to beat each other
physically mentally and emotionally the
reason for their numerous many unmarried
girls drugs recording pressures drugs
girls drugs
[Laughter]
a result in the back like most married
couples they simply couldn't talk to
each other anymore
Makar in Jack's words being antisocial
and giving up feeling isolated and alone
on the road fair enough make sure you
suffer crippling anxiety for most of our
life but no no really unfair you have to
talk to raid you're on your own
eventually led to the end they stopped
speaking at all which would be fine
where they tied to each other in
long-term performance contracts which
they were forced to regrow Juliana years
after until broke down number four
Simon and Gotha is but would you believe
that the biggest risk to develop between
one of the biggest jewels and music
history stemmed from jealousy felt by
Paul Simon yes after Simon drawling
catch-22 was current he had to spend
months setting back in the studio
waiting for God for them to return so
they can finish bridge over troubled
water the delay on the album Wow
reverse the notion up until that point
but it was art he was being overshadowed
this tension owns complete lack of
balance which was now free flowing from
both sides was even obvious to George
Harrison who told art my polish to me
what your call is to you which loosely
translates as you suck mate which must
have stung
Mulder and Scully virtually every scene
together which made the company's
revelation that they couldn't stand the
sight of each other one of the more
surprising Gillian Anderson corroborates
this story admitting that there were
long periods of time during the shows
run weather - didn't talk at all and
that they could both be pains in the
arts
she also recalls that she felt
ostracized for getting pregnant during
the second season of the show pay
disparity between the two actors and
[Music]
because he was already called his taller
sidekick the rudest man uninvolved in a
good chunk of the actual building saying
is rarely on set and his name appears on
the credits it's more of a good luck
charm or a courtesy bit like when we
dueled on the rest of channel this
passive-aggressive droid few dates back
to an incident that you had on set many
moons ago with Baker claims you whether
to say hello it was co-star Oh to be
shut down by
turned his back on him and said can't
you see I'm having a conversation but
you quite happily talk about the dislike
brought another in interviews in number
one Liam and the old Gallagher another
pair of brothers in the music industry
or anywhere else when you loathe each
other as much as the Gallagher's and
after years of being convinced that
their constant mud sling was just there
to build interest in a reunion tour it's
now widely accepted that they simply
cannot stand each other in turmoil is
widely documented by this point with
tensions between the two hot-tempered
brothers rising with each ensuing album
both as part of a voices and more
recently their solo projects the feud
came to a head after the recent terror
attacks in Manchester with Noel's
inability to return to the country for a
benefit concert leading Liam to tell him
to get on a [ __ ] plane and play your
tunes for the kids you sad this is a
heartbreaking listen I know how they
integrated like this like micro sketch
really not getting a log like setting up
that ending punchline this whole time
some of that's pretty heartbreaking I
feel like John and I are like this I
mean I can tell I mean there's always
tension between John and I it's very
sexual oh really yeah
I'll keep your secret yeah but he's
always bringing girls back to the
apartment like a lotta Crocs and then I
get filled with jealousy mm-hmm
get me a wreck John a lot of these
shocked me Dean Martin and Jerry Lewis
the ones with the bands I could actually
see it easier for them to set aside
their differences in terms of like okay
I get why they haven't created anything
new for a long time but they just do
performances that seems plausible to me
to for them to do that but when you have
like a TV show together we've created a
legendary duel out of it from constantly
creating and rehearsing together working
together and feeding off each others
energy which I guess can be set up a
band but it's a little bit of a
different format for actors and for
Jerry Lewis and Dean Cain and Kane Dean
Martin that was shocking especially
because they're so funny together some
people that make you laugh so much
together actually hate each other I find
that a little bit more heartbreak it's
like if I found out the cast of friends
hated each other that was surprising and
then it sucks because they've built so
much up from that I wonder how it true
that is that if Dean Martin actually
said you're just a dollar that's John
said that to me many times and I pay him
mm-hmm
hoping it'll lead somewhere it never
does
he doesn't seem to respect your feelings
he doesn't but that's why I'm drawn to
him gosh yeah you like that yeah my
parents were very neglectful so
naturally I'm drawn to emotionally
unavailable men understand one day one
day I'll change a man make him who I
want him to be I will save myself in the
process okay The Rolling Stones yeah
I've heard about Mick Jagger yeah
they're not getting along before but
they're so Pro though they still perform
together if they still do an excellent
job whenever they're on stage which is
very respectable yeah they just still
just make it work when you get to set
aside your differences I think like
Christian pull off and marquel let's do
that all the time oh yeah that's why
they're the only ones in the Schmo down
in front of the camera I've actually get
along with each other but really behind
the scenes mark is just Christian's
little [ __ ]
Wow don't worry they don't watch my
videos okay good specific I read in
school everyone talking about Jack and
Meg why did you listen to the White
Stripes though there one song you heard
all the time the seven nation army I
heard like weird rumors about her they
were like brother and sister first and
then I heard they were married then it
just got very confusing yeah I remember
hearing about that and being like I
don't even know who these people what's
crazy though is Jack White's career is
still like yeah he's like four bands
it's not the composes for movies every
ways everywhere he collabs with everyone
and I've never hear about mag do you
think that's a woman thing you know like
like how discriminatory the
entertainment business there's the women
I'm trying to make this a controversial
video trying to get this content okay
you're a woman speak up for a woman me
too
do it yes that is the industry being
like [ __ ] you you're a woman you heard
it here first you heard it here first
screw Jack White that's a man pressure a
woman no idea about that breaks my heart
Abbott and Costello Meet Frankenstein
was one of the most viewed movies I
watched growing up as a kid so to hear
this piece of information actually like
is really disheartening to me yeah yeah
it's disheartening but at the same time
their chemistry on camera wasn't that
they got along perfectly their chemistry
was that they always bickered and
bantered with each other which I feel
like can be more fun if you don't get a
lot yeah cuz it's kind of an outlet in
the moment in front of the camera to
just channel that's why they were so
good because I could just channel it I'm
acting with you right now but not yeah
exactly
not like Christian and Mark Mulder and
Scully you know I've heard I've heard
some pretty awful things about David
Duchovny I actually have to I mean I'm
kind of a creepy guy yeah especially I
don't know what it is but lately it's
been kind of coming around that these
two yeah and it's cuz they have they're
the x-files coming back
they are one of the most the biggest
duo's of all time those examples that
were showing of like mold or always
having to walk in front of Scully the
pay differences yeah I don't know if
that's still going on with the show I
wasn't having a really a big x-files fan
to begin with everyone knows that Mulder
and Scully's even if you've never
watched the x-files yeah it's a pretty
good chance you're still gonna know who
that is
that is unfair because they are equal I
wouldn't want to watch just a Mulder
show no when I'm on with just a Scully
show so they should be treated equally
probably why they never got together in
the multiple movies and multiple sees
nothing done no like will they won't
they just nemesis no they're not going
to because I don't think these two
actors will ever and c-3po r2d2 he's got
a great profile isn't it it's a great
actor duo ever I didn't know there was
an actual like an actor really I mean
that's gonna lose me so much credibility
with all geeks I felt like maybe they
had like a stunt performer in there or
something because he doesn't have lines
or do anything no really I mean but
here's the thing about that story when
they listed both sides of the arguments
of that they had I was like well the guy
who plays c-3po sounds like a dick
that's what I came I'm like hey oh I
didn't even knows an actor as r2d2 but
be the guy plays c-3po sounds like you
he was kind of a big pretty big Jersey
guy that would be more heartbreaking to
me if I knew there was an actual actor
is that's just unfortunate because I
feel like for the most part when you
think Star Wars you think that the cast
is all like friends yeah like a great
time
and then it's like well alright he was
going around just being a dick to
everybody
damn yeah well everyone knows that you
know like yeah we all like our Luc's and
Leia's and hans but everyone shows up
for c-3po well obvious yeah he's the
highlight of all I wish they could do a
c-3po spin-off Gallagher yeah that's a
pretty big one huh I feel like most
people know yeah but they're brothers so
they're always gonna be in each other's
lives in some way even if they don't
talk to each other for like a few years
they'll eventually just have to come
back around to seeing each other again
my brother he lives in the building next
door he has a channel that just
surpassed us and followers he's a total
douche oh my he's such a dick good I
kind of like him a little bit a little
bit okay I mean he helps me out with
money but that's all he's really good
for I love my brother anyway thanks to
our culture for your video guys this is
a great video Taylor it's 3:30 you have
to head back to Arizona get on the road
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified every time one of our
videos is up cuz subscribe buttons don't
work also make sure to subscribe to
Taylor's channel finely tailored because
she is fine and has good suits that's
why they come here class a calm